bootleg cat podcast man we got enes in
the building some friends out right now
you see the album
physical copy [__] tell them Kev we
ain't playing but it's also online
everywhere it's available on Spotify no
no this is official it's official yeah
well listen the official ones are online
go stream it online all right let's go
get it yeah listen man uh new battle
coming with you say a war a war yeah
that's on the way but let's get to These
Bars man bars
[Music]
baby
cut through blunt smoke coming out the
squatter we getting pulled over by the
cop helicopters made [__] four deep
like the gravediggers a 747 to the World
Trade Center I'm anthrax stand back
Spring Water I'm King Kong playing ping
pong with your daughter you standing
over there like you got something for us
like Mr monster Tyrannosaurus I'm
gigantic Titanic God damn it I'm
everywhere jamming innocent bystanders
it's the praying mantis off with his
head to the getaway car then I'm off
with his bread I pledge allegiance to
the Leisure the doom and don't think
that he wrapped that he ain't a goon and
gotta be a full moon for the wolf to
come out I give you half for the clips
like when Pusher come out let's go
come on man
hey man I just also want to shout out
I'm bootleg Kev and since you're here we
have to just make it obvious that I'm
not Cosmic Kev because I get confused
for Cosmic Kev all the time and I know
you've gone and burned down shout out to
Cosmic Kev He's a Philly Legend okay
okay shout out to my DJ Cosmic Kev but
this is the bootleg Kev yes okay shout
out to Cosmic Kev but this is bootleg
Kev the podcast we have to make it let's
be clear there it is let's go fire hey I
know you just watched a new freestyle
guess what we're dropping them every
week sometimes more than once a week
Jesus we've been dropping a lot lately
uh shout out to LRG don't forget go to
l-r-g.com use the promo code bootleg
save 30 off here to check out you get
this look at this jacket look at that
lining
it's LRG baby 30 off this bad boy go to
l-r-g.com promo code bootleg and save 30
off at checkout and check out another
freestyle next week